alors sur le fond est-ce que c'est une
bonne idée oui ou non donc de réviser
notre constitution de vouloir la réviser
pour mieux maîtriser notre politique
migratoire d'abord vous voyez ce que je
vous disais ces gens saturent l'espace
politique avec les questions
d'immigration tout le temps c'est on
vient de finir l'examen du bien sûr on
vient de finir l'examen du projet de loi
immigration au Sénat qu'on a maintenant
dans le cadre de la niche DLR un débat
sur la réforme de la Constitution et
alors la réforme de la Constitution
uniquement autour de de de l'enjeu mais
vous dites que ça se termine en fiasco
ça se termin en fiasco parce que à force
de jouer avec le feu on finit par se
cramer c'est exactement ce qui est en
train de se produire et je n'en suis pas
insatisfait parce que je pense
effectivement que ça peut leur servir de
leçon j'espère qu'un jour quand même au
Parlement on pourra débattre des vrais
problèmes des gens les salaires le
travail tout ce qui fait que aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens disent qu'ils auront
pas les moyens de payer des cadeaux de
Noël pour leurs
enfants